à lire et comprendre là il ya beaucoup
il ya de plus en plus de récompenser les
victoires il ya des césars yakan il ya
le goncourt il ya les molières et les 7
d'or et angoulême la bande dessinée
angoulême maintiens que je vous vois ou
chela tête la huberdeau bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous vous avez eu tort de faire
comme ça alors espérer 280 millions
d'exemplaires le film est parti pour
faire quoi
10 millions 12 millions qui hossa ouais
mais il est dopé l'astérix triche un peu
il ya du dopage alors on parle des
récompenses donc les récompenses on va
commencer que les victoires de la
musique puisque l'été on était sur la
chanson donc dites nous pascal sevran
dont on donne une récompense la personne
qui reçoit la récompense est contenté
soyez assez pâle c'est celui qui la
reçoit donc j'avais bien commencé
attendait ben oui on va pas se raconter
d'histoires l'heure qu'il est on peut se
dire la vérité
bachand tout le monde aime bien qu'à
chaud aussi tout le monde aime bien oui
il y'a bon est ce que lui est-ce que
bâchée pas comment on fait pour est ce
que est ce que batch ou est-ce que
bashung c'est pas parce qu'il est sympa
et que tout le monde aime bien qu'on lui
donne parce que regarder par exemple
julien clerc par exemple il l'aura
jamais pourtant il fait des trucs
formidables métier le métier n'aime pas
julien clerc donc on lui donne pas de
victoire mais alors qu'on l'annoncé si
le métier même paju la clé la preuve le
public allait beaucoup de mérite
oui c'est un très grand mais je viens
jamais obispo par exemple il a rien eu
pourtant aux bisous mais c'est un
formidable
et comme il avait plutôt pour cl comme
il a un peu la grosse tête en bas les
bijoux en génération
je suis attendu non non non invasive
très bon signe pour julien et pour lui
ce pot ouais je vois leur donne pas les
victoires
je trouve que c'est très bien fait dans
la litote la vie voilà vous avez un 7
d'or vous thierry jamet bavera et
pourtant vous êtes bon bah je suis bon
méchant méchant alors justement voilà
quelqu'un vous uderzo avec goscinny en
25 ans je n'ai jamais été récompensé à
angoulême par le prix de la bande
dessinée mais je n'ai pas le public
qu'on pensait tout le temps il s'est
certes c'est à dire comme mon voisin
moyens quand on vous a donné le prix du
millénaire
c'est tellement visite avant il avait 25
ans qu'on travaille qu'on a travaillé
pendant 25 ans on n'a jamais eu de prix
et maintenant vous nous le donner le
prix du millénaire aujourd'hui et vous
avez commencé par le refuser donc c'est
bien que ça doit avoir une importante en
vous comme elle et ça ne l'est pas
refusé c'est une journaliste qui n'a pas
compris ce que je lui expliquais il fait
commence évidemment à réagir en disant
quand même que j'en avais gros sur la
patate
surtout sur la sphère le cinéma je suis
encore vivant pu me défendre et goscinny
qui est décédé comme en scène n'a jamais
eu de prix alors qu'il a apportés par
cette profession
quelque chose considère attendait bon or
je lui expliquer tout ça elle en a
déduit que je refusais le prix way dont
le lendemain dans la dans le journal le
journal jmf eu dans un refuge le prix
laurent témoin gulam évidemment bien
entendu où il va y aura une conférence
de presse
on téléphone à ma fille qui s'occupe un
peu de mes affaires et je dis non c'est
pas vrai je voulais faire mais refuser
celui se trouve que j'ai quand même
guise le venin sur le ventre pas vous
dites quand même
excusez-moi refusent-ils quand même là
les récompenses ça n'a pas d'importance
mais goscinny les morts sans en avoir eu
c'est bien dommage ça me fait mal aux
vrais voilà donc c'est bien que ça de la
portance entraînant le vent c'est à dire
excellent alors y'a pas que si ça te
faire lui aussi sont les oubliées
non c'est mauvais signe quand on a une
vraie comprends ça aide après c'est les
commandes prises à deux césars oui c'est
comme ça et puis plus tard je viens à
chaque fois qu il nous fit l'impoli
toute façon ça se gâte ils veulent plus
de nous le lendemain ouais mais c'est
très curieux c'est comme si nous a lu le
juge
pour celui qui fait mal aux fusées
cercueil quoi on passe à la suite on va
regarder allemagne et qu on a regardé un
match nul sur quelqu'un qui a eu un
césar et que ça a beaucoup ému
j'espère que tu es fier de moi syrie moi
si tu savais comme je suis fier d'avoir
été talent a vraiment c'est un beau
cadeau qu'on m'ait fait dans ma vie
effigie je voudrais remercier tous les
joints qui m'ont donné de l'amour tous
les ans j'ai croisé dans ma vie parce
que j'ai rencontré des gens qui ont été
très généreux avec moi je voudrais
remercier mon père parce que il m'a
porté sur ses épaules depuis des années
et ils mettent tous les jours et fait un
père formidable je voudrais lui dire
combien je laime
romane bohringer allait bien donc oui je
fais une fois dans une émission m'aviez
dit j'aimerais te papa vous lui disiez
c'était une auto interview
oui didier j'aimerais pas que tu
deviennes commune de ces satanés actrice
insupportable elle n'est pas devenue
comme ça non pas du tout non voici une
bonne comédienne alors qu'on va faire
comme dans le cas de stephen contrôler
ex ante et c'est moi qu'elle a alors lu
ces questions serait ce que pour des
moments comme ça c'est bien mais on va
évidemment autrement et du punk médias
vous dites vous la voyez pas ce que
vettel s'est cassé la saison et depuis
je le vois plus à la télé qu'ailleurs
non mais ça c'est un truc qui datent de
l'info parce que maintenant
non elle s'est cassée à 16 ans parce
qu'elle est partie faire du théâtre
ouais elle peter brook et elle est
partie au tour du monde
ouais donc la saison c'est un peu court
pour un père qu'on préférerait qu'elle
porte un peu plus tard donc quelques
années qui sont restés vous voyez on
rattrape tout ça beaucoup voient en ce
moment alors par défaut de films